rarement timing aura été aussi mal
choisi ce mardi l'union européenne a mis
à jour sa liste noire des paradis
fiscaux pas pour y ajouter de nouveaux
mauvais élèves non c'est tout l'inversé
trois territoires en ont été retirés les
seychelles anglia et la dominique la
décision d'aujourd'hui de retirer
anguilles à la seule juridiction
restantes avec un taux d'imposition de 0
% et les seychelles qui sont au coeur du
dernier scandale fiscal fait de la liste
noire de l'ue eux une plaisanterie et
oui les seychelles ce nom revient à
plusieurs reprises dans les pandora
paper vous savez ce scandale financier
d'envergure mondiale a révélé il y a
quelques jours par un consortium de
journalistes selon l' enquête au cours
des dernières années plusieurs sociétés
offshore auraient été créés dans cet
archipel de l'océan indien
l'une au bénéfice de l'ancien député
français centriste et maire de blois
nicolas perruchot d'autres créés par
aymeric chauprade l'ex-député européen
ex conseiller de marine le pen les
seychelles hébergerait également des
sociétés liées au milieu marseillais ou
office d'intermédiaire en armement alors
pourquoi est ce que ce territoire a été
retirée de la liste noire ce mardi parce
qu'il s'est engagé à mettre en oeuvre
les réformes de transparence fiscale
demandées par l'union européenne sauf
qu'entre la parole et les actes il ya un
monde mais de toute façon cette liste
noire européenne des paradis fiscaux ne
recense en réalité qu'une petite partie
des juridictions encourageant l'évasion
fiscale la liste noire ne comprend pas
un seul des vingt pire paradis fiscaux
pour les entreprises dans le monde
identifié par tax justice network en
2021 ni aucun des quinze pire paradis
fiscaux pour les entreprises dans le
monde identifié par l'analyse toujours
pertinente d'oxfam en 2016 bon nombre
des pires paradis fiscaux pour les
entreprises sont des états membres ou
des territoires de lieux comme les pays
bas le luxembourg et l'irlande pourtant
la liste noire de l'ue continue
d'exempter les pays européens et oui
d'ailleurs de nombreuses autres
territoires cité dans les pandora paper
ce ne figure pas sur la liste dubai
monaco chypre chypre dont le président
nicolas anastacia death apparaît lui
aussi dans les pandora paper ce tout
comme le premier ministre tchèque andré
mba bis ou le mini néerlandais des
finances vox hoekstra le ministre
néerlandais des finances c'est à dire
qu'ils participent donc à la mise à jour
de la liste noire sur les paradis
fiscaux sauf ce mardi logique vu la
polémique de quoi alimenter certains
soupçons que la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale ne serait pas menée avec le plus
grand emprunt difficile de leur donner
tort d'autant que le préjudice lui il
est colossal selon l' ocde ce sont dix
mille milliards d'euros qui dorment dans
les paradis fiscaux c'est à peu près les
trois quarts du pib de l'union
européenne